[Music]
good morning Johnny it's Thursday
October 25th today is a very special
episode of brotherhood 2.0 in which I am
going to take you all back into the
history of my life have arrived at my
dad's house in Fairview North Carolina
and I suddenly am surrounded by a member
ease of my childhood and these memories
include things such as Yuda unopened
which I'm sure is worth noting
probably substantially less than the
$6.74 that I paid for it there is a big
box here of everything that ever
mattered in my life one thing that
mattered a great deal in my life is
Dexter Dexter wave hi Oh Dexter talks
this is the animal that I slept with
every night for a long time some people
have teddy bears
I have Teddy black-footed ferrets that's
what you get when you're down at the
Florida State Director of the Nature
Conservancy going back further in time
this is Skye likes my blankie though
this was even more early sort of love
and sleep time I know what you're
thinking Skye Lex isn't really a normal
name for a kid's blankie you're right
it's a weird name for a kid's blankie a
normal name would be BB which was your
blankies name I would like to point out
that neither of our blankets have
anagram Abell names this is the research
that I did in college the novel
differentiation of human blood
mononuclear cells into CD one a negative
dendritic cells is stimulated by the
absence of exogenous cytokines by an
extra prepared from pine cones oh
nerdfighters what that translates to is
cancer cure from pine cones if you look
really hard you can see my name in there
somewhere
look at my transcript I only see
calculus - here's a little mystery for
you this is some piece of ever our
chemistry department and it seems to say
on it YouTube why would it say YouTube
on it ah my first publication space
times it's the magazine of the American
Astronomical Society first Caves ideas
and opinions let's go to Mars by Hank
green if you want to read that you can
google me and the word Mars and you will
likely find it it is very embarrassing
but I was 16 and it was nice to get the
from them saying that they would like to
publish it what else do we have there is
this which is possibly the most
flattering picture of me in history and
it was on the front page of the
lifestyle section because I made a
website called it I hate I for comm
which if you live in Orlando you do hate
i-4 and so people could relate to it it
got me in the paper this is an
interesting article I'd never read it
until I found it in here pretty cool the
site doesn't exist anymore don't go to
try to find it I was a founding member
of the Mars Society
I hid myself in that not society I
regret that I cannot share more of this
stuff with you because there is a ton of
a really good fodder for making fun of
myself for example this is a sheet that
contains many of the ticket stuffs that
I used to go in and see the Rocky Horror
Picture Show which I did many many many
many many many times and then there's
this which is my best dancer award which
note I actually did win the best dancer
award at my high school Hertz and I am
apparently allergic to it but I cannot
share all of that with you because so
much of my life is in that box it's very
strange to go through I'm glad that I
could share some of it with you because
I'm sure John that you don't know a lot
of stuff about me which is crazy and if
you have a box like this I would love to
see your version I don't know if mom and
dad have it here haha I'm going to ask
in any case John I hope you enjoyed that
Dexter and I will see you tomorrow
Maggie's nose man's nose